ah j'adore me confesser
là je trouve ça sexy bah
alors Richard dans la série confession
d'un barjot suite
et tu favorable au divorce
je m'interdis d'y penser
j'aime l'idée qu'un couple aille loin
ensemble j'aime ça
à l'avortement
parce que j'entends toujours des gens
dire comme moi l'avortement mais c'est
ok je comprends l'idée de vie mais il y
a des gens qui se retrouvent dans des
situations absolument infernales quoi ou
Dieu même Dieu de la haut à toute sa
miséricorde faudrait peut-être lui
demander à lui plutôt que de demander à
ses serviteurs pas la peine de mort non
même pour les assassins d'enfants
bah oui je suis obligé de continuer à la
légalisation des drogues douces
ouais ça c'est un vaste débat j'ai connu
certaines légalisations à Londres dans
les années 60 à Amsterdam en Hollande on
connaît aussi
je sais pas
[Musique]
c'est quand même que autour des lycées
des petites écoles il y a quand même un
maximum d'enfoirés
dedans en France qui voudront quand ils
seront au moment où on peut dire oui ou
non
en fait tu sais pas
quelles sont tes tabous tabou tabou
tabou ce qui me choque
à vrai dire tout choc moi-même même je
me choque
quand
je suis choquant
quand je suis un dessin
orgueilleux vaniteux
moins en moins comme ça moi je trouve
ouais mais il y a encore du boulot à
faire
déjà fait pas mal
est-ce que tu crois en Dieu
je crois autre chose qui vibre je crois
à la zébrure divine oui
tu crois au diable
il doit y avoir un diable sympathique et
puis un diable parfaitement tordu c'est
sûr donc je crois au diable sympathique
mais je crois aussi au diable
complètement tordue les événements il
faut bien qu'ils Dieppe qui soit dans
cette affaire là parce que donc le
diable j'y crois
mais pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna Lady tube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu